jesse seems to be in just about
everything these days including in this
chair right here next to us i think we
took the shot too early he was also in
breaking bad and black mirror and in
martin scorsese he's the irishman along
with many many other things and he's now
appearing in jane campion's western
drama the power of the dog which is
getting rave reviews for good reason
clemen's co-stars include
benedict cumberbatch and once again
the great and lovely partner kirsten
dunst take a look
four two three
side two
what is it george
i just
don't want to see how nice it is
not to be alone
it's lovely scene and jesse plemons
joins us now as nate points out it's a
great mustache on that character thank
you as gayle has pointed out to me this
is not really a western it's more of a
family drama that happens to be set in
the west uh and i want to get into your
character the story but but first it's
got to be interesting working
as a husband and wife in the role with
your actual partner what was that
experience like
it's the second time we've done that and
um
we're hoping to just continue working
together makes logistically makes it a
lot easier
yeah is it more complicated than it
would be with a just a oh i think i
think the opposite you know
there's there's a shorthand that you
have with your spouse and you can kind
of cut through everything
and any idea that either one of us have
we can kind of throw it out without you
know any ego being attached to it and
it's just it's so much fun and she's so
so incredible i would think you know
when i see my wife we always talk about
things that a husband and wife talks
about like did you pick up that did you
get that what about the thing but you're
playing characters so do you keep your
real life to the sidelines
so you're asking like in between scenes
yeah did she like and and cut and cut
are you like hey did you see that text
message what are we going to do about
the school thing you don't get that
no you know i don't i guess i guess i'm
just lucky all right yeah no she said
this film she's quoted saying this film
would have been harder to do if she
wasn't working with her favorite actor
which would be you jesse
and so i'm wondering what it was like
for you because i was reading that you
would you guys would go out and you
would film her
in restaurants what were you filming
what were you helping her with
do you know this about drinking
oh yeah that's right yes
there were because that's such a huge
part of her character yes yes yes drunk
or tipsy for a large part of the film
um so yeah i did i did there were a few
you know
nights of research where i i helped her
out and then filmed or something but but
how do you describe it because it's
right it's sort of a psychological
thriller your brother is a horrible
character
he's he's he's terrible with you but yet
you have a quiet strength standing up
against benedict cumberbatch batch in
the movie you have a quiet strength
standing up to him but it's a
psychological thriller because you're on
the edge of your seat waiting to see
what you think is going to happen in
this movie many different times yeah i
think it sort of appears at first like a
western you know opens up and
beautiful landscape this cattle drive um
and then the the the more you get into
it i think that's kind of what makes it
interesting is you're trying to figure
out what what it is that you're watching
and
you're slowly meeting these
meeting these new characters and it does
turn into kind of a classic
drama that i feel like could have been
it could have come out of the 50s or or
something but at the same time there's a
there's a tension
and a poetry to it that i think only jan
campbell camp yeah her first film in 12
years yeah yeah this this film explores
the idea of people putting on fronts
which is completely relatable um kind of
explain that dynamic in this movie
well
that was one of the things that i that i
found so interesting about the
the script and the novel is you know
three out of the four characters they're
sort of not living their truly authentic
self you know and
some of that is is time and place you
know it's montana in the 20s
but the interesting thing is the
youngest character peter in the uh in
the in the film
is is
sort of given the hardest time about who
he is but he's the most at peace in his
own skin you know right um
but yeah what do you like most about
what you get to do jesse because this is
people know you from friday night lights
i remember you in breaking bad you know
you play creepy very very well this is
not a creepy guy i play creepy very very
well this is a decent guy no he is he
really is i loved your character what is
it you like about what you get to do
because you're you're you're acting as
you're is it versatile versus one of the
best in the business yeah thank you very
much that's the word i was looking for
versatile yeah what i enjoy is is it's
it's the most
interesting way to learn you know
you sort of find yourself in these
worlds that
you know maybe you would you you would
read about but it's there's something uh
that's that's a totally different
experience when you're kind of inside of
it you know and um i really enjoy the
research side of it yeah
getting to work with
with the best which i've just been so
fortunate to work with so many talented
people so if you're flipping through and
friday night lights is on do you stop
and watch it
uh yeah i would i haven't in a while
flipping through jesse thank you very
much the movie is compulsively watchable
it's brilliant congratulations on it's
called the power of the dog that's the
first line from the bible in select
theaters now released on netflix
december 1st